Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
We have had plenty of episodes about fluid
simulations, so how about some tasty soft
body dynamics for today?
Soft body dynamics basically means computing
what happens when we smash together different
deformable objects.
Examples include folding sheets, playing around
with noodles, or torturing armadillos.
I think this is a nice and representative
showcase of the immense joys of computer graphics
research!
The key to real-time physically based simulations
is parallelism.
Parallelism means that we have many of the
same units working together in harmony.
Imagine if we had to assign 50 people to work
together to make a coffee in the same kitchen.
As you may imagine, they would trip over each
other, and the result would be chaos, not
productivity.
Such a process would not scale favorably,
because as we would add more people after
around 3 or 4, the productivity would not
increase, but drop significantly.
You can often hear a similar example of 9
pregnant women not being able to give birth
to a baby in one month.
For better scaling, we have to subdivide a
bigger task into small tasks in a way that
these people can work independently.
The more independently they can work, the
better the productivity will scale as we add
more people.
In software engineering, these virtual people
we like call threads, or compute units.
As of 2016, mid-tier processors are equipped
with 4-8 logical cores, and for a video card,
we typically have compute units in the order
of hundreds.
So if we wish to develop efficient algorithms,
we have to make sure that these big simulation
tasks are subdivided in a way so that these
threads are not tripping over each other.
And the big contribution of this piece of
work is a technique to distribute the computation
tasks to these compute units in a way that
they are working on independent chunks of
the problem.
This is achieved via using graph coloring,
which is a technique typically used for designing
seating plans, exam timetabling, solving sudoku
puzzles and similar assignment tasks.
It not only works in an absolutely spectacular
manner, but graph theory is an immensely beautiful
subfield of mathematics, so additional style
points to the authors!
The technique produces remarkably realistic
animations and requires only 15 milliseconds
per frame, which means that this technique
can render over 60 frames per second comfortably.
And the other most important factor is that
this technique is also stable, meaning that
it offers an appropriate solution, even when
many other techniques fail to deliver.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!